hier soir première au palais des sports
d'eddy mitchell un spectacle qui a
enthousiasmé l'ensemble de la presse un
spectacle mis en scène par jérôme savary
le monsieur du grand magic circus marie
claire gauthier assister aux dernières
répétitions d'eddy mitchell
on pense à la première fois ça doit
remonter aux années aux années héroïques
suis présenté 1 361 quelque chose comme
ça
les vents d'hiver fumeurs comme
l'appellent ses amis assistent en
théâtre mogador au spectacle rock pour
les bébés boyau du magic c'est plus le
cochon qui voulaient maigrir signé
jérôme savary rencontre déclic pour
palais des sports aujourd'hui
eddy mitchell nous en scène par jérôme
savary ses grands dieux the moi très
grand mérite des 10 pour ceux pour ce
concert c'est justement de ne pas avoir
mégoter sur le sur la partie spectacle
avec laquelle on a dû que vous met du
temps je veux dire à ses amis
parce que qui d'abord ça s'appelle des
sports c'est bien ce que ça veut dire et
que on a mis beaucoup de temps quand je
dis on je pense à tous les chanteurs qui
sont passés sur cette scène à trouver la
bonne sonorisation a trouvé les montants
de première et a eu beaucoup de 10 ont
eu beaucoup de déception c'est pas du
tout du théâtre attention à ces pas
bredouille et c'est pas que c'est pas le
chanteur de mexico avec eddy mitchell
dans le rôle du chanteur
c'est elie mitchell le thème principal
du spectacle
le
tu veux
salon
com
tu
oh
m
elie mitchell chante juste jambes bien
ça balance et pour moi offenbach quand
c'est bien fait sa loi va lancer aussi
mozart sa balance aussi il ya aucune
différence entre eddy mitchell et
l'opéra et d'ailleurs je pense que eddy
mitchell pourrait très bien chanté à
l'opéra
ça leur ferait du bien d'ailleurs
je t'en prie pour eddy mitchell au
palais des sports du nouveau dans
l'équipe